hello this episode is sponsored by
tic-tock which means we're gonna show
you something from tick-tock right now
here is a message from one of our
favorite creators at Chuck's dumpster
does that boring old Elf on the Shelf
not do it for you anymore
we got something brand-new that will
really spice things up this holiday
season Sarah in the corner just like the
elf from the shelf she's there and then
she's not except this time it's a little
it's a little more awkward than before
you can get your own today for the low
price of 399 Sarah in the corner oh god
why does she stand like that to see more
of sharks dumpster and other tik-tok
creators you can check them out in the
link below in the description down there
and now you can watch the video but we
brought together seven Christmas lovers
I love the holidays I love the holidays
[Music]
one is a Scrooge if the group discovers
who the liar is they'll split a cash
prize if the liar survives they win the
entire prize
why don't we do everyone like Christmas
movies yeah okay all right I really love
jingle all the way
mine is white Christmas so mine is home
alone classic and Batman Returns - movie
it's gotta be number one you know my
favorite is Fred Claus and they'll be
the Grinch for me as white Christmas a
childhood classic grandma got ran over
by a reindeer How the Grinch Stole
Christmas and the Christmas girl
wow you all sound like you love
Christmas yeah I was the fat man
confident
[Music]
ouch
all right Batman Returns die hard I mean
these are all Christmas movies to me it
sounded a little iffy and it sounded
like he was trying to think on the fly
for an answer the main question we
should ask is why do we like Christmas I
like Christmas because I have a really
tight-knit family so for us that's a
time that we get to just be together
about Jesus to me but at the same time
there's also a lot of other stuff like
getting together with family and just
giving gifts is always fun I also like
it cuz is December so it's my birthday
and my mom's birthday so it's just
celebration after celebration it's like
the season of like cold and they like
savings and everyone's like to prep but
then there's Christmas so there's the
whole like spirit of like happiness and
just seeing your friends and family
spend a lot of my time with my family
during Christmas it's also my birthday
so it's like a huge celebration question
do you get double presents or yeah yeah
I get double presents so yeah all right
what do y'all think is the best time to
put up the tree yeah after Thanksgiving
but last year I had my tree all year
round for Thanksgiving cuz it's
something we like to look at when we're
eating Thanksgiving dinner yeah I have
this free and like the music and stuff
what do you tell your kids about Santa
Claus yeah I actually think that like
the real-life Santa Claus was like a
pretty cool person yeah I think yeah you
can like raise your kids being like yeah
Santa Claus is a real person that's what
I was brought up learning is the
obviously season and forgiveness of
giving my family really wanted me to
just learn about like the core meaning
of Christmas so I think that's something
[Music]
I was honestly mainly suspicious of the
guys I just felt like you can rely on
girls to the board to be into things
like that I just thought she was
piggybacking off of other people's
answers it's not me the question was
when do you guys put up your Christmas
trees or something and then he said like
oh no like that has to be after
Thanksgiving like it can't be too early
so then that threw me off and then I was
like I think I need to get him I think
it's him do you guys have any specific
like family traditions that you guys do
for me growing up in Puerto Rico we have
this thing called fat Honda's which is
like yeah you're familiar yeah oh really
it's like um it's kind of like caroling
but you go like house to house and
there's a lot of eating there's a lot of
like like people have like instruments
to play and sing carols every single
year me and my family try to come up
with like a specific Christmas pajama
that we're gonna wear for yeah that's
cute hmm I don't know like everyone kind
of wears pajamas so instead of doing
gingerbread houses we do gingerbread
trains literally just get graham
crackers and you make the train but it's
fun because obviously you can put
whatever candy you want to put on it
it's so cute I mean I suggest doing have
any like Christmas dinner like specific
foods that you guys eat at Christmastime
or oh my god yeah like like here since
they sell like tamales I'm like where
can I get them tamales
I really left it as leches cake
[Music]
she was a little quiet and at times she
didn't really say like much details she
just like seemed like a little to put
together very nice and sweet and I was
looking for a little bit of grit she
wasn't saying any specific details
besides her train
I felt like everything she was saying
which is more stereotypical of what
people tend to do on the holidays
especially Hispanic families the
hard-hitting question I want to play
devil's advocate okay why if you if you
were them all I'm not saying that you're
the mole
why would you hate Christmas I just
wanted to catch somebody all nervous and
sweating maybe someone had like a really
bad experience like something maybe like
a death on it on the day I know that's
the premise for movies like all my
movies like I hate Christmas just like
knowing the people that I know that
don't like Christmas mostly just because
it's like so commercial and oh yeah
there's like the capitalist aspect of it
like they might not buy into buying
stuff for people me okay so you guys
really quick how do you rank the other
holidays go rank them like one two yeah
although I like Christmas Oh Christmas
Halloween
um maybe my birthday Easter I like
fourth of July Thanksgiving Oh
Thanksgiving because of all the food
good food yeah it's somewhere in there
Thanksgiving
Halloween's dead
I don't know spacious isn't like you
don't like costume
no not really I feel good really good
[Music]
oh my birthday's on Christmas my family
obviously made it clear that like I was
more important than the holiday oh
that's me but when it came to like
friends it was more about like oh it's
Christmas and oh yeah it's your birthday
I forgot oh okay
[Laughter]
when we had to list off the holidays on
how he ranked them as soon as I threw
Halloween at the very end I kind of saw
the faces that everybody made those
faces just straight-up told him like I
that's it you're out once I found out
that Emilio was Puerto Rican that's
right I don't know I just something
there's there was a connection there
somewhat of an alliance throughout the
round they had gained my trust and I was
a gibbous if one of them is a mole
within
[Music]
hi guys my name is Sarah also known as
the new-and-improved up on the shelf
Sarah in the corner thank you so much
for watching and you can find me on tic
toc at tricks dumpster
bye thanks for watching the video and
you can download tic toc in the
description good day
[Music]